In today's video,
we're doing a few more
experiments with the ink removed
from ballpoint pens.
[Music]
A while back,
we took 1000 ballpoint pens,
and removed all
of the ink from them,
and collected it.
And we still have probably
800 pens worth of that ink.
Maybe a little less,
but we've got quite a bit.
This is just a pool of pen ink,
and since we did that, we asked
what we could do with it,
and we had several responses.
So today we've got
five common requests,
and we're going to try them out,
and see what happens
with our pen ink.
I still think
my idea was the best.
Your idea was to paint
your nails with it.
I'm just painting my nails.
With what?
Pen ink.
She's thrilled.
I'm not going to paint
my nails with pen ink,
but here's hoping
that works out for you.
I guess it's a really cool
metallic black coppery color.
It's beautiful.
Here's the basic idea.
We've got five suggestions
of things to try
with ballpoint pen ink.
We're going to go
through the one by one,
and see what the results are.
Let's go through our comments
one at a time.
Our first comment comes
from Charlene McClintock,
who asks us to do a test to see
if pen ink is magnetic.
Calli has a very
powerful magnet in her hands.
Let's show the power
of that magnet off
a little bit for a second.
I'm pretty sure this magnet has
a 100 pound pull strength,
which means if it's
on a flat piece of metal
that is attracted to,
it takes a 100 pounds pulling
it straight away from it.
Obviously, the way
to remove it without that much
for us is to use leverage,
twist it at an angle,
pull it off.
So very powerful magnet.
Let's see if it wants to do
anything at all to our ink.
It's not sticking to my nails.
The nails...
No effect.
That is a very very
thin layer of the ink.
That is true.
This is probably like less
than a drop of ink guys.
This stuff has
great coating power.
This however is
about a cup of ink.
So let's see
if we get any result.
I'm going to start by putting it
on the side of the glass.
So it doesn't just
stick to our magnet
if it's magnetic.
Anything?
Can you feel it pull it all?
Nope, I feel no pull.
I see no ripples in ink.
Without the glass,
in case the glass is what's
causing the lack of magnetism.
Well, whatever is in this ink
that's making it metallic,
it's apparently not magnetic.
It does look metallic,
and maybe they're actually
is real metal in ink.
I don't know the full
chemical composition of ink.
But not all metals are magnetic.
The three elemental metals
that are attracted
to magnets are iron,
nickel, and cobalt,
and some of their alloys.
Steel for example is an alloy
of iron and carbon,
and sometimes other things,
that usually is
attracted to magnets.
Thank you for your suggestion.
It would have been
really cool if it were,
because that would've been
like a really cheap
source of ferrofluid.
No magnetism here.
Alright, so for
our next comment,
we have got one
from mamasboy -99.
How would electricity
work in the pen ink?
So you can see,
when I touch the two
metal pieces together,
it's a very bright little light
that we've got there.
Put something in
the way of that,
like my tongue.
Lights up a tiny bit.
Not as much.
So there's something in the way.
Alright, so first as
a comparison control test,
just regular water.
So here's how bright
it is without anything.
And then in the water.
Very light glow.
Now, pure water
distilled water probably
would give us no result.
But this is tap water,
it's got minerals
in it, imperfections.
But now we're adding salt,
which hopefully will
make it even better.
Well, that's quite a bit--
Yeah.
Okay.
Still not as bright as
the wires touching however.
Let's try the ink.
And into the ink.
[Music]
There actually is
a tiny tiny little purple.
Oh, you're very--
Are you sure it's
not a reflection?
Yeah.
So you can see
that the wires are about
two inches apart in ink,
and that's giving
us an extremely low,
but not nothing glow on our LED.
It's much worse than salt water,
and it's actually worse
than non saltwater.
So mamasboy -99,
we do have conductivity
through the ink,
but so little
that it barely counts.
Our next comment request
comes from Icey Paw,
who says, try putting
dry ice into pen ink.
I'm just going to dip it,
and see what happens.
[Music]
That did not stick.
Sticking to the plier.
Yeah, the pliers
are getting stuck to it.
But look at that,
it's actually--
Oh, it's freezing
ink in streams.
Here.
Try and-- Try and let's see
if we can like capture--
Pliers it together.
Oh, that's weird.
So odd.
Because it's still
a liquid, guys.
We're just freezing it.
The bottom, where it's
actually in contact,
I think is...
Yes.
Started to freeze.
Oh no.
See it like that.
Sucked my glove immediately.
See if I can flip it over.
No, it's stuck in my hand.
Oh no.
This is weird,
because it's like partly frozen
so it's like gummy.
This part starting to dull.
It's actually...
Oh, it is.
Look at that.
You're actually--
>> You frozen the ink.
>> Frozen all the way through.
All right, I'm going to try
and pull it off of that.
Oh my goodness.
Look at that.
It's just a chunk.
Okay, I'm gonna
destroy my gloves,
but that's fun.
Clay is a really
good description, but it's--
Except it's
melting into sticky--
If you were to mix clay
and slime, but it's...
It has this give of like a gummy
candy almost, except it's--
It is warming up rapidly,
and quickly just
destroying my gloves.
Yeah.
This elastic texture
is not something
that I was expecting,
but my goodness, it's fun.
[Music]
I win.
Did you get it out?
I did.
Good.
Well, I think we should progress
to mixing even more dry ice in.
That was the comment,
is try putting dry ice
into the pen ink.
We've done everything,
but that so...
So here it goes.
Yeah.
Dry ice.
[Music]
Yes.
That's kind of what I
was hoping it would have do.
So I got some pretty
good shots blowing bubbles
into the ink last time, but now,
as it seals up over the dry ice,
it just makes its own bubbles
as the dry ice tries to expand.
So while Nate plays with that,
we've got another common request.
I apologize if I
butcher this name.
I believe it as Ha Seung Jung,
mix it with soap,
and then blow ink bubbles.
It's so cold now
from the dry ice,
that we still got
this pulled taffy consistency.
Yeah, you can already see
that there's like this cool
gold sheen happening.
Okay.
So if anybody ever wants to make
their own homemade galaxies,
ink and dish soap.
We are going to try
and blow ink bubbles,
but this may be
a little too viscous.
This is just ink and soap,
so we've added a little bit
of water to this one.
Let's see what we can do.
[Music]
Well.
That's a nice bubble.
It's pretty though.
So ink and soap together,
not really making bubbles,
but this ink, soap,
and water is.
With that weird mixture
that Nate's got,
it really just looks
like he's blowing blood bubbles.
That's freaking cool.
Well now, I'm going
to start popping bubbles,
because I don't want them
to expand up out of the cup.
Here. Wait, hang on.
This was an awesome idea.
It didn't go quite
the way we planned,
but it was still cool.
Our last request
is from OLIVERS758,
who asks if we
can dehydrate the pen ink.
We've got two things
we're going to try.
One, we're gonna throw some ink
in our Dehydro-tron,
little dehydrating machine
we've used before,
and the other is the reason
that this has been
on the counter the whole time,
is this is our freeze-dryer.
And we're going
to see what happens
if we freeze dry ink.
We don't know
how this is going to go.
We don't know how far
this is going to expand.
So we're just going
to do a small amount
in a very large jar,
and hope it contains it.
You may remember,
when we first
vacuumed some ink,
it bubble up a lot,
and the clear sides of the cup
that it was in just turned
completely black immediately,
and then you couldn't really see
what was happening
inside anymore.
There's a decent chance the same
thing is going to happen here.
We've seen some liquids
bubble up a lot.
Will ink do the same thing?
We're not sure.
We've seen how rigid it gets
when it gets cold,
and the freeze dryer
does get very cold.
It might be enough to stop it
from moving at all.
We can see...
We can look at it after 24,
and see if we think
it's doing well.
Side benefit, we're testing
out what happens
if you put a GoPro
in a freeze dryer.
It may not survive.
And I know the burning
question you all had,
did my nail
survive this experiment?
Yes. They did.
Our ink has been run
through the freeze dryer
and the dehydrator
for about a day and a half now.
Coming up on two days
at this point actually,
and we think
that at least one
of them is finished.
It's gonna be very cold.
First off...
See if our GoPro survived.
Sorry little GoPro.
I mean, the battery is almost
certainly dead at this point.
It's very cold GoPro.
I just wonder if we
can even turn it on again.
That would be a fun experiment.
We'll see if this lived.
Okay.
This is my new
favorite thing ever.
[Music]
Wow.
So obviously, this part
is all very very dry.
This is very cold to hold.
You can see if it's frosting up.
Still getting ink marks.
This might be the prettiest
stained glass thing ever.
It's kind of going gummy.
Interesting.
Okay, around the edges.
It's still a little squishy.
That's some fairly warm water.
Not too hot.
We don't want to risk breaking
the cup or anything like that.
This is from our internal GoPro,
which apparently did survive
its trip through
the vacuum chamber-- Whoop!
And there goes the ink.
That's amazing.
It explodes.
Which is funny,
because like it doesn't look
like there's any air
bubbles in ink.
But it's just sitting
there for a while,
but apparently, there's enough
that degases in low pressure,
that it just creates
all of those bubbles.
Like obviously,
a ton of bubbles.
That was insane.
And you can see what it's done
to our perfectly clear glass.
Wow.
At this point,
the glass is warmed back up.
It's not frozen there.
This is the same powdery
dry ice substance here.
However, down at the bottom...
Now that you've warmed
it back up.
Yeah, it was frozen in there,
and we saw with the dry ice
how it gets really thick
when it freezes.
But now, this is warmed back up.
Alright, so we've exhausted
just about everything
that we can do with
the freeze dried ink.
Now, we want to see
what happened to
our dehydrated ink.
[Music]
Well, that's cool.
You can see all of the places
where the ink hasn't dried
yet of my handprint.
What's in here?
Okay, seems fairly liquid.
This is our common request,
asking if we could
dehydrate the ink.
It is very thoroughly
become inundated with the ink.
That's now the rest of our ink.
Yes.
And the freeze-dried.
Yeah, this is
the rest of our ink,
and everything was freeze-dried.
So you can still see like
the viscosity here, but now,
if I do the same thing to
what we put in the dehydrator...
It's a--
It's a little gumier.
It does look
like it's sticking
a little bit more.
But that's about it.
It's still, it's still ink.
In our first video
where we took the ink
out of a thousand pens,
there were dozens,
and possibly hundreds
of comments saying
that instead of taking the ink
out of the thousand pens,
we should have just
bought the ink online,
and you can buy ink online.
But it's not this kind of ink.
Pen ink that you buy online
is much much thinner.
It's designed for
like a quill pen,
or a fountain pen
that you dip into the ink,
or you refill a well,
and then you try
and draw with that.
It's not the same thing.
This would not work
in a fountain pen.
This stuff is as thick
as corn syrup,
and this is not the consistency
that you normally have
in a bottle of ink.
So while, it would have been
easier to buy a bottle of ink,
it's just completely different.
We wouldn't have learned
what's inside ballpoint pens.
We wouldn't really know
anything about that ink,
because it's just too different.
Another thing to mention is
that when it comes to India ink,
the reason people like it
is the quality of the...
Honestly, the blackness
of the color.
It's very very dark,
and there's no shine to it.
Ballpoint pen ink is usually
known for having the sort
of metallic quality.
You're not going to get
that with India ink,
or true India ink.
Guys, that's it for today.
But you know,
the fun doesn't end.
We've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top
will take you to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box
is going to show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
If you hit this bomb
here in the middle,
you'll be subscribed
to the channel.
So you never miss
out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.